Now using object as a structuring mechanism, let's talk
about objectization of the memory management function. We first start
with the address space of the process. The address space
of the process is shared by all the threads, and
there's gotta be representation for the address space, and
that is your process object. And it is shared by
all the threads that are executing on the CPU. So
we can think of this process object as somewhat equivalent
to the process control block in a tradition
setting. Now what we wanted to do is,
we're going to take this address space. Remember that
I mentioned I don't want a centralized data
structure that describes the address space. Because, intuitively,
if you think about the multi-traded application, the
different trade of the application maybe accessing different
portions of the address space and therefore, there is
no reason to have a centralized data structure in the
operating system to describe the entire address space of that process.
So what we're going to do is we're going to take the
address space. And break it into regions. So there's a green
region here and a purple region here. So, the green
region is a portion of the address space. The, the purple
region is another portion of the address space. Logically, they are
all part of the operating system, data structure of the page
table, but what we have done is we have
sort of detonated the page table data structure, essential
data structure, and said that well there is a
portion of this page table data structure The green region,
another portion is the purple region and of course,
these regions have to be backed by files on the
storage sub system so, we will call them, these
objects as File Cache Managers, so similar to breaking up
the address space into regions, we are going to carve up the backing store also
into what we call File Cache Manager that backs each one of these regions, so,
for instance, This FCM1 is a piece of the storage subsystem that
backs this region R1 and similarly FCM2 backs this region R2.
Of course for any of these threads to do their work the
regions that they're executing in They have to be
in physical memory, so that they can actually get
to the instructions and data corresponding to that portion
of the address space, and therefore we need a page
frame manager, and the page frame manager is also
going to be implemented as an object, a DRAM object, and
this DRAM object is the one that serves page
frames, so when You, when the page fault service needs
to get a page frame, it contacts a page
frame DRAM object in order to get a physical
page frame so that it can then move the
contents of this backing file the file cache manager
for that particular region and bring that from the
storage subsystem Into the DRAM, for future use by
a particular thread. So that is another object, and
of course, you have to do the input output
in order to move the page from the, back in store into DRAM, and so
we going to declare that there'll be another object
which we'll call the cached object representation COR,
and this is the one that is going to be responsible for knowing The location of
the object that your looking for on the backing store and do the actual page IO.